hey everyone
i welcome you to this session by simply
learn
in this session we shall make sure that
you get to know about all the important
selenium interview questions that you
might be asked in your upcoming selenium
interview
selenium tester or selenium developer is
one of the most
popular jobs in devops domain according
to idita labs a research company which
uses data to provide
industry insights found that nearly 31
of software testing tools market
belonged to selenium in the year 2018.
the stats tell a lot about how preferred
selenium is
all across the world selenium skills are
highly in demand as the automation
testing market goes on increasing
professionals with these skills are hard
to find
so there are ample amount of jobs in the
market for skilled candidates
companies are even willing to go beyond
the industry norms
for compensating their selenium testers
provided
they have the required certifications
and experience
the median salary of selenium testers in
the uk currently falls in the range of
forty thousand pounds per annum to sixty
five thousand pounds per annum
the average salary of a selenium
automation tester in the us
is around ninety seven thousand five
hundred dollars per annum
if we talk concerning india the average
salary of
selenium tester is 19 lakhs per annum
and the salary of a selenium
professional falls between
1 million per annum to 4.2 million
rupees per annum this variation in
salary depends on
various factors such as job location
experience
education employer certifications and
many more the salary trends gave a great
idea of what you can expect from the
carrier
so now when we know at what great height
is the demand of selenium in the market
let's go on and check the top 50
selenium interview questions
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and
hit that bell icon so that you can never
miss an update from
simply learn we have divided the
questions into three parts
depending on the level of difficulty
okay
without further ado let's get started
with our first part that is the beginner
level interview questions
so the first question is what is the
main purpose of selenium
so the answer for this question is
selenium is an
open source automated testing tool used
to test web applications
across various browsers desktop and
mobile apps cannot be tested using
selenium however other tools like hp's
qtp and
appium can be used to test software and
mobile applications
it is a cloud-based testing platform
that allows testers to record their
actions and export them
selenium enables parallel test execution
which
increases the efficiency of tests
selenium can test web applications
against browsers like
firefox opera chrome and safari
to name a few the test code can be
written in various programming languages
like
java perl python and php
selenium is platform independent and can
be deployed on
different operating systems like windows
linux and
macintosh selenium can be integrated
with
third-party software tools like junit
and
testng for test management selenium is
not just a single tool but
a suit of software each with different
approach to support automation testing
it comprises of four major components
which include
selenium integrated development
enterprise selenium remote control now
deprecated web driver and finally
selenium grid
now moving on to the next question what
do you understand by
automation testing automation testing
uses
automation tools to write and execute
test cases
in this case no manual involvement is
needed for executing an
automated test suit testers prefer
automation tools to write test scripts
and test cases
and then group them into test suits
automation testing enables the use of
specialized tools to automate the
execution of
manually designed test cases without any
human intervention
automation testing tools may access the
test data
control the execution of tests and
compare the actual result against the
expected result
and finally generating detailed test
reports of the system
under test now
the third question is what are the
advantages of
automation testing this is one of the
most
asked interview questions in any
automation testing job
some of the advantages of automation
testing are
the tool supports both performance and
functional testing
it supports the execution of parallel
test cases
it enables parallel execution in the
combination of
different operating systems and browser
environments
there is minimal manual intervention and
test scripts
can be run unattended this reduces the
chances of
human errors there is reusability of
code that is
create one time and execute multiple
times
with less or no maintenance
automation testing saves time and money
and is faster in execution
in automation testing there are easy
reporting which means it generates
automatic reports after execution
it is easy for compatibility testing and
is cheaper
compared to manual testing in the long
run
automated testing is more reliable more
powerful
and versatile automation tools allow us
to integrate with
cross browser testing tools jenkins
github
etc it is mostly used for regression
testing and supports execution of
repeated test cases
now moving on to the fourth question
what is the difference between selenium
2.0
and selenium 3.0
selenium 2 is nothing but integration of
webdriver
with selenium rc or selenium 1.
selenium 1 is a well-established
framework that supports various browsers
due to its javascript implementation
the strengths of both the selenium web
driver and
selenium one are combined in silly name
two
which makes it obvious that the
drawbacks were earlier there
will no longer be there in 2.0 on the
other hand in the case of selenium 3.0
selenium 3.0 can be referred to as an
extended version of selenium 2.0 solving
bucks and increasing stability
the big chance in the selenium 3.0 is
the core being replaced by
back into web driver it won't be wrong
to say that
selenium 3 would be majorly be the
choice of software testing tool for both
web and mobile based applications now
moving ahead on to the fifth question
what are the testing types supported by
selenium
so the answer for this question is
testing types that can be supported by
selenium are as follows
functional testing regression testing
re-testing acceptance testing end-to-end
testing
smoke testing sanity testing responsive
testing
cross browser testing ui testing
integration testing
and many more moving on to the next
question what are the different
selenium suit components so the answer
for this question
is there are four components in selenium
suit
first is the selenium remote control or
selenium rc selenium remote control
enables the writing of
automated web applications in languages
such as
java c-sharp etc
it is hardly in use today as the
webdriver offers
more powerful functionalities the second
is the selenium grid
selenium grid enables the running of
tests in parallel
on several machines the commands are
routed to the remote web browser
instances and
one server acts as the hub the hub is
responsible for conducting
several tests on multiple machines the
third
is the selenium ide selenium ide needs
no additional setup except installing
the extension
on your browser the ide makes the test
debugging easier with features like
setting breakpoints and pausing
exceptions
and the last and the fourth tool in the
suit is selenium
web driver selenium webdriver is the
most
critical component of the selenium tool
suit that allows
cross browser compatibility testing the
web driver supports
various operating systems like windows
mac
linux unix etc
now let's go on further and check the
next question
what are the different programming
languages browsers and operating systems
supported by selenium so the answer for
this question is
selenium supports various programming
languages to write
test code with language specific drivers
that offer commands
from the selenium api the common
language is used
by testers to write selenium code are
c sharp java perl php
python and ruby java is the favorite
language
for use with selenium one and two but
the ease of using python and ruby has
led to many testers
opting for these languages as well
so moving on to the next part of the
question which deals with the browsers
supported by selenium the main reason
for selenium's popularity is the wide
and comprehensive list of features
available on the platform
with selenium test execution remains
seamless on
just about all available web browsers to
name a few
we have google chrome mozilla firefox
internet explorer
opera safari and edge
so now let's talk with the respect to
operating systems that could be
integrated with selenium
selenium enables creating and testing
suits on any platform
and executing their test cases on
different one
for example the tester could write test
cases using windows operating system
and then run them on a linux based
operating system
so to name a few selenium can support
android ios
windows linux mac and solaris
now let's go on and see the next
question
what are the advantages of webdriver
over selenium
rc so the answer for this question is
webdriver is faster in comparison to
selenium rc
because of its simple architecture the
web driver
can directly communicate to the browser
while selenium rc
needs the rc servers to help to do so
web driver api is more concise than
selenium rc
and can support html unit while selenium
rc
cannot selenium webdriver tool
is used for automating web application
testing to verify that
it works as expected or not
it mainly supports browsers like firefox
chrome safari
and internet explorer it also permits
you to execute cross browser testing
the next question here is why testers
choose selenium over
qtp so the answer for this question is
selenium is an open source tool and it
is specifically designed to test
web-based applications in selenium
we can execute tests when a browser is
minimized
whereas in qtp we need to have an
application under test to be visible on
the desktop
in selenium multiple cases can be
executed in parallel
unlike qtp where we can execute only
one test at a time there are
several browsers supported by selenium
while qtp just supports internet
explorers
on windows selenium supports mobile
devices like
android iphone blackberry headless
webkit
whereas on the other hand qtp uses a
commercial product for mobile app test
automation that is
hp uft mobile selenium supports
different programming languages while
qtb supports only
visual basic script and also selenium
has
zero maintenance cost as it is open
source whereas qtp has a license
and annual maintenance charges so now
these were the few reasons why
testers mainly chose selenium over qtp
now moving ahead into our next question
what is the use of xpath
so the answer for this question is xpath
is a selenium technique
used to navigate through the html
structure of a web page
it uses a non xml syntax to provide
a way of pointing to different parts of
an xml document
it can also be used to test address
nodes
within a document to determine whether
they match a pattern
or not while other locators in selenium
that search for elements using tags or
css class names
are simpler to use they may not be
sufficient to select all dom elements of
the html document
the primary purpose of xpath is to
address parts of the xml document
now moving on to the next question how
can you locate
a web element in selenium so the answer
is
selenium uses locators to locate and
identify
web elements there are different types
of locators in selenium
some of the locators are mentioned here
the first type of xpath locator is the
id the best
and the most popular method to identify
web elements
is to use id and obviously each
element's id
is definitely unique the second type is
the class name
in this case the class name of the
element is used to find the element
the third type is the link test where
the text of the link
is used to find the element all the
hyperlinks on a web page can be
identified using linked text
the links on the web page can be
determined with the help of anchor tag
the anchor tag is used to create the
hyperlinks on the web page and the text
between the opening and
closing of anchor tags constitutes the
link text
then comes the xpath locator that uses
the name of the element to find
that particular element the other type
of xpath locator is the x path
this required to find the dynamic
element and
to traverse between different elements
of the web page
the last type of xpath locator is the
css
path it locates the elements to have no
class
name or id now moving ahead into the
next question
name the different types of web driver
apis
so the answer for this question is the
web driver api
refers to the standard that abstracts
out the device
or browser specific bindings from the
developer
so that the test script can be written
in any programming language
and run on many different browsers
via a web driver the different types of
web driver
api in selenium are android driver
chrome driver event firing web driver
firefox driver html unit driver
internet explorer driver iphone driver
iphone simulator driver
remote web driver now moving ahead into
the next question
what does a slash signify in xpath
and what is the difference between
single and
double slash the answer for this
question is
the xpath syntaxes are path expressions
that are used for addressing into a
document
slashes are used to create xpath with an
absolute or relative path
xpath uses path expressions to select
nodes in an xml document
there are two cases one is the single
slash
where the other is the double slash
single slash creates
xpath with an absolute path which means
that the x path would be made to begin
selecting from the start
node double slash on the other hand
creates
x path with a relative path which means
that xpath
would be made to begin selecting from
anywhere
in the document now moving on to the
next
question explain absolute x-path and
relative x-path so the answer for this
question is
absolute x-path starts from the root
note
and ends at the desired descendant
elements
node it starts with the top html node
and
ends with the input node it starts with
a single forward slash
as we discussed in the previous question
while on the other hand
the relative xpath begins from the
middle of the html dom structure
relative xpath starts from any node in
between the html page
and the current elements node and it
starts with a double forward slash
then the other point of consideration is
the difference in the drawback and the
case of absolute xpath
is that if there are any chances in the
elements path
then xpath will fail and in the case of
relative xpath
it enables writing from the middle of
the html dom structure
without any need to write the long x
path
we can see the syntax of the two
absolute xpath
and relative xpath on screen and we can
notice the difference
in the slashes in case of both of them
now moving on to the next question name
some automation tools that can be
integrated with selenium
to achieve continuous testing
selenium can be integrated with several
automation tools
some of them are maven jenkins
docker test ng junit
iphone driver iphone simulator driver
remote web driver
now moving on to the next question
differentiate
between verify and asset commands
assets and verify methods are commonly
used in selenium for verifying
or validating applications if the asset
condition is true
then the program control will execute
the next step
but if the condition is false then the
execution will stop
and further test steps will not be
executed
whereas in the verifying condition there
won't be any pause in the test execution
even though the verify condition is true
or false
there are two different types of assets
the hard asset
and the soft asset while there are no
categories in case of verification
the hard asset condition throws an
exception immediately after the asset
fails and carries out
with the next case of the suit on the
other hand
while the soft asset condition does not
throw an exception immediately
when the assertion fails collects them
and carries out
with the next validation now moving on
to the next
question what are the different types of
junit annotations
which are used in selenium junit
annotation is a special form of
syntactic metadata
that could be added to java source code
for better code readability and
structure
annotations were introduced in junit 4
which makes the java code
more readable and simple the different
types of junit annotations are
test before after before class
after class ignore run with
now the next question in the docket is
how is
test ng better than junit test
ng and junit are both open source
frameworks supported by selenium web
driver
test ng is a testing framework based on
j
unit and n unit to simplify a broad
range of testing needs
from unit testing to integration testing
there are more functionalities added to
test ng which makes it more powerful
than junit test ng enables dependency
testing
which isn't there in junit now moving on
to the next question
what are the different types of selenium
frameworks
the selenium framework is what makes
code maintenance easy and
efficient with our frameworks users
might place the code
and data simultaneously which is neither
reusable
nor readable there are beneficial
outcomes
or frameworks like increased code
reusability
higher portability reduced script
maintenance cost
better code readability and many more
there are three types of frameworks
created by selenium webdriver
to automate manual test cases the first
type is
data-driven the data-driven framework in
selenium refers to the method of
separating data sets
from the test case then the second
framework is the keyword driven
framework
this framework is a method used for
speeding up automated testing
by separating keywords for common sets
of functions and instructions
then the third framework is the hybrid
framework where we utilize the
advantages of both
the keyword driven framework as well as
data-driven framework
now let's move on to the next question
what
is data-driven and keyword driven
data-driven framework is based on
several data sets generated in
external file and then import it to the
automation testing tool
hence test data is generated from
external files like excel
csv or xml the data sets are separate
from the original script
from which the required input may be
fetched
let's check on what is keyword driven
framework now
the idea behind the keyword driven
approach in automation is to separate
the coding from the test case and test
step
this helps a non-technical person to
understand the automation
very well the instructions required to
perform the operation are written in an
external file
like excel sheet which keeps most of the
data
and keyword driven which is needed for
the test like test case
test steps test objects and actions
the functionalities to be tested can be
easily controlled by the users
so this was all about the beginners
level of interview questions
now let's go on further and check some
intermediate level of interview
questions
that might help you take a step further
in your preparation
now the 21st question is what is
selenium webdriver so the answer for
this question is
selenium webdriver is the most important
component of the selenium tool suit
the webdriver allows cross browser
compatibility testing and supports
various operating systems like windows
mac
linux unix and etc
it also provides compatibility with a
range of languages including python
java perl ruby etc
the web driver provides support for many
different browsers like
chrome firefox opera etc
and provides faster execution of the
test scripts compared to other tools
the next question is what is the need of
selenium
webdriver so the answer for this
question is
selenium webdriver provides a very
user-friendly interface that could be
easily understood
web driver is a programming interface
that helps create
and run test cases it makes provision to
act on web elements
the web driver has many other features
in comparison to selenium rc
and selenium ide now moving on to the
next
question how is the selenium webdriver
different from selenium rc and selenium
ide
selenium webdriver is an open source
collection of apis
which is used to test web applications
the selenium webdriver tool is used for
automating
web application testing to verify that
it works
as expected or not unlike
the selenium ide selenium webdriver can
work with
many different browsers then the web
driver does not require the user to
start the server as
in case of selenium rc
selenium webdriver is an api and not a
graphical user interface
based plugin or a standalone java
application
in selenium webdriver all the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature
unlike the other tool in addition to
that selenium webdriver supports
listeners otherwise woes implementation
is not
supported the webdriver also supports
ios and android testing
which is not supported by rc and ide
now let's move on to the next question
what is the architecture of
selenium a web driver selenium webdriver
architecture
in a simplified diagram is shown on the
screen
selenium webdriver api enables
interaction between browsers and
browser drivers this architecture
consists of four layers namely the
selenium language bindings json wire
protocol
browser drivers and real drivers
selenium language bindings consists of
languages like
java ruby python c sharp and
so on after the test cases are triggered
entire selenium code will be converted
to json format
json stands for javascript object
notation
it takes up the task of transferring
information from the server
to the client json wire protocol is
primarily responsible for the transfer
of data between
http servers generated json is made
available to browser drivers through
http protocol
each browser has a specific browser
driver
browser drivers interact with their
respective browsers and
execute the commands by interpreting
json received from the browser
as soon as the browser driver gets any
instructions
they run them on the real driver or
browsers
the response is given back in the form
of the http response
moving forward to the next question that
is the 25th
question what are the drawbacks of
selenium webdriver selenium webdriver
does not support
testing for desktop applications it
requires
the expertise of team and resources to
manage
no inbuilt reporting capability test
reports are generated with the help of
plugins like
junit and ng and also requires
a lot of maintenance and it is difficult
to scale
if you want to get the technical issues
resolved one must trust the community
forums
in selenium webdriver testing of
images is not possible for testing of
images
integration of selenium with sickly is
needed
the next question is how does selenium
grid
works so the answer for this question is
selenium grid is a smart proxy server
that makes it easy
to run tests in parallel on multiple
machines
this is done by routing commands to
remote web browser instances where
one server acts as the hub the hub is
responsible for conducting several tests
on multiple machines
now moving on to the next question what
are some of the common exceptions in
selenium webdriver
the answer is automation code execution
usually
may not carry out as expected due to
many factors
involved in execution such as network
stability issues
internet issues server stability etc
we might get exceptions due to
insufficient waiting time or
incorrect syntaxes parameters etc
some of the most common exceptions are
no such element exception
no windows exception no such frames
exception
no alert present exception invalid
selector exception
element not visible exception element
not
selectable exception timeout exception
no such a session exception now
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between
type and type and weight command
so the answer for this question is the
two commands
type and type and weight command have
their own specific purpose
the purpose of type command is to type
keyboard
key values in the text box the command
can be used to select
the value of combo box whereas
the type in weight command is used when
the typing is completed
and the web page starts loading the
command waits for the software
application page
to reload now the next question
what is the difference between find
element and
find elements in selenium
here the find element command is used to
identify
a web element within a web page it
returns the first
web element that matches the search in
case there are
multiple elements and throws an
exception called no
such elements exception if the element
is not found
whereas the find elements command is
used to identify a list of web elements
within a page
it returns the list of elements that
match
more than one element and does not throw
an exception
but returns an empty list if there are
no matching elements
now moving on to the next question what
is meant
by weight in selenium how many types of
weights are there
in selenium the weight functions are
very essential when it comes to
executing selenium tests
they help in observing and
troubleshooting the issues
that may occur due to variation in long
time
in automation testing weight commands
direct the test execution to pause for a
certain
length of time before moving on to the
next step
there are two types of weight commands
they are the implicit weight and the
explicit weight
first we will learn the implicit weight
implicit weights
tell the web driver to wait for a
certain amount of time before it throws
an exception
once we set the time webdriver will wait
for the element based on the time
we set before it throws an exception the
default setting is
zero we need to set some wait time to
make
webdriver to wait for a required time
now we will learn about the explicit
weight the explicit to weight in
selenium is used to tell the web driver
to wait for a certain condition or
maximum time exceeded before throwing an
exception
that is the element not a visible
exception
moving on to the next question
what is the biggest disadvantage of
implicit
weight the main disadvantage of the
implicit weight is that it slows down
the test performance
webdriver will wait for some specific
amount of time before it throws an
exception
for example if you set the waiting time
to be 10 seconds
and the elements appear in the dom in 11
seconds
your test will fail because you told to
wait
for a maximum of 10 seconds only
now moving on to the next question what
are the type of
navigation commands so the different
types of navigation commands are
the first one driver dot navigate
to url this navigates to the provided
url
then comes driver.navigate.refresh
this method refreshes the current page
the third command
is the driver.navigate.forward this
method
does the same operation as clicking on
forward button
of any browser it neither accepts nor
returns anything
last navigation command is the
driver.navigate.pack
this method does the same operation as
clicking on the
back button of any browser it neither
accepts
nor returns anything moving on to the
next question
what is meant by same origin policy and
how is it handled same origin policy is
a feature
taken for security purposes
according to this policy a web browser
enables the access of scripts
from one web page to the other if both
the pages have the same origin
the origin policy protects a malicious
script on
one page to access sensitive data on
another
followed by this we have the next
question what is salinas and how
is it classified salinas is a set of
selenium commands which are used to test
your web application
testers can test the broken links the
existence of some objects on the ui
ajax functionality alerts on window
list options and a lot more using
cylinders
selenium commands tells the selenium
automation engine to perform certain
tasks
cylinders can be classified into a set
of three types of commands
which are action accessors and
assertions moving ahead we have the 35th
question what is the difference between
driver.close method
and driver.quit method so the answer for
this question
is the driver.close command is used to
close the current browser window
if there are multiple windows open on
the screen then
the one on focus will be closed whereas
the driver.quit command is also used for
the same purpose
if there are multiple browser windows
open on the screen
then the command closes all of them at
once
moving ahead we have the advanced level
of interview questions
now we are done with the intermediate
level of selenium interview questions
let's now buckle up a little more and
learn the advanced level of interview
questions
the first question in this category is
how do you type
text in an input box using selenium
the method used to type text in input
boxes is
send keys the send keys method allows
typing automatically into an editable
field during the execution of
any tests these fields are web elements
that can be identified using locators
like
element id name class name
etc now moving on to the next question
how to click on a hyperlink in selenium
the command used to click on the
hyperlink uses
link text to find the element the
command finds the element using
linked text and then clicks on the
element
where after the user would be redirected
to the corresponding page
you can find the syntax of the command
on the screen
moving on to the next question how to
scroll down a page using
javascript the method used to scroll
down to a page is scroll by we can see
the syntaxes of a set of commands the
first syntax that is the execute script
here
is the general syntax for scroll by
command then the second syntax of
javascript executor is
create a javascript object then the
third syntax
driver.get is the syntax of launching
the desired application
then the last syntax that is the js
dot execute script is for the scroll
down to the desired location
moving forward we have the next question
what is the way of typing in a text box
without using send keys the text can be
entered into a text box
by using javascript executor the
commands that could be used
for the process can be seen on the
screen you can use
javascript executor and jse dot
execute script for the work to be done
now moving forward we have the next
question how to select a value from a
drop down in selenium web driver
for selecting and deselecting from a
drop down in selenium web driver
select class is used the objects of
select type can be initialized by
passing
the drop down web element as a parameter
to its constructor
the syntax of the commands can be seen
on the screen
the web element test drop command and
the command to select the drop down
here the web driver offers three ways to
select
from a drop down box the first way is to
select a buy index that is the selection
is based on index starting from zero
then comes select by value that is
selection based on value
the last way is select by visual text
that is selection of option that
displays text matching
the given argument the next question is
what is the use of switch to command the
answer for this question is
the switch to command is used to switch
between windows
frames or pop-ups within the application
every window instantiated by the
webdriver is given a unique alphanumeric
value called
window handle we can see the syntax of
commands on the screen
the first command that is the string
handle command is used to get the window
handle
of the window you wish to switch to and
then
the driver dot switch to command is used
to switch to
the desired window the next question is
what is meant by object repository in
selenium webdriver
an object repository is a common storage
location for all
objects if we talk in the context of
selenium webdriver
these objects would typically be the
locators used to identify
web elements uniquely for example if
there is a chance
in one web elements locator value then
only the object repository
has to be changed instead of all the
test cases
the object repositories have to be built
in selenium webdriver
using the key value pair approach the
two types of object repositories
may be created in selenium webdriver are
the
first one object repository using
properties file and the next one
object repository in xml moving ahead we
have the 43rd question
how to upload a file in selenium web
driver
to upload a file in selenium webdriver
the send keys or robot class method
are used the initial step is to first
locate the text box and then set the
file path using send keys method and
click on submit
the syntax for the command can be seen
on the screen
the first syntax of the web element
command is used to locate
the browse button then the second syntax
of the browse dot
send keys is used to pass the file path
to
be uploaded using send keys method
moving on to the next question
what is the way to set browser window
size in selenium
so the answer for this question is the
window size can be maximized
set or resized to maximize the window we
use the
dot driver.manage.window.max method or
command
and then to set the window size we can
use
dimension d is equals to new dimension
where in the brackets we give the
dimensions we want to set
the size now moving on to the next
question how can you debug test and
selenium ide
the steps to debug the test and selenium
ide are
the first step is to insert a breakpoint
from the place you want to execute your
test
then execute the text case after the
test case has started executing
the execution will pass at the
breakpoint then
click on the blue button with the next
statement to continue and finally
click on the run button to execute all
the commands
moving ahead we have the next question
how to insert a breakpoint in selenium
ide
the steps to insert a breakpoint in
selenium ide are
the first step is to go into the
selenium ide
right click on the command and select
toggle breakpoint
then select the command and press the b
key on the keyboard
pause that to clear the breakpoint press
b
key again and multiple breakpoints can
be set up in the selenium ide
moving forward we have the next question
what is a pause on
an exception in selenium ide so the
answer for this question
is the pause on an exception as a
feature
that is used to handle exceptions in
selenium ide
the feature can be used by clicking on
the pause button on the right
top corner of the ide window the
execution stops when an exception is
encountered
and the script enters to the debug mode
so the entire test
does not fail and the error can be
resolved
moving forward we have the 48th question
what can result in the failure of
selenium ide
so the answer for this question is
selenium ide is one of the most
accessible record and play tools in the
selenium tool suit
which requires no particular setup the
selenium ide
comes with a very rich set of commands
powered by surnase and
allows us to record and test different
web application
interactions with the browser but then
there are certain times when the
selenium ide might
fail some of those instances are when
selenium cannot locate the element
if the locator has changed then one more
such instance is when the element to be
accessed cannot be found on the web page
and operation is timed out
and one more case is when the element
being tried
to access is not created
for finding if the link is broken or
working fine we use the driver.get
method
when we use driver.getmethod to navigate
to a url
it will respond with a status of 200
okay
200 ok denotes that the link is working
and it has been obtained if any other
status is obtained then it indicates
that the link
is broken some of the http status quotes
are
200 that indicates it's a valid link 4.4
indicates link not found 400 indicates
bad request 4.1 indicates unauthorized
and finally 500 that indicates internal
error and now we are at the last
question
how to login to any site if it is
showing an authentication pop-up
for user name and password so the answer
for this question is
to handle authentication pop-ups we need
to verify its appearance
and then handle them using an explicit
weight command
the syntax of the explicit weight
command to be used is on the screen that
is
the first syntax webdriver weight syntax
the second syntax is the alert alert
equals to weight dot
until refers to the use of alert class
to verify the alert
and the last syntax is alert dot
authenticate that is there to provide
the credentials after the verification
in the previous step
and this is all for this session i hope
that after going through these
selenium interview questions you would
have understood what kind of
questions can be asked in your interview
and how you could approach them
in the best possible manner signing off
on this note subscribe to our channel
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here